grâce à cet appareil vous allez pouvoir
savoir en 60 secondes si vous avez un
virus respiratoire la boîte s'appelle
vira warn enfin vous avez quoi vous
soufflez dedans cinq fois et en 60
secondes vous aurez soit une lumière
rouge vous disant que vous avez un virus
respiratoire notamment le covid 19 ou
alors une lumière verte quelqu'un vous
n'avez absolument pas de virus
respiratoire et tout va bien donc là
c'est vachement cool parce que en fait
vous pouvez faire jusqu'à 100 tests et
ça coûte 100 dollars mais sachez que
vous avez 5 recharges dedans vous avez
la batterie là ça permet de faire des
tests ça coûte moins cher et surtout
vous saurez directement si vous êtes
positif ou non ils ont développé une
autre solution qui est vachement bien
c'est ce petit truc là que vous venez
vous mettez sur vous et en fait lorsque
vous rencontrez quelqu'un que quelqu'un
vous parle et bien il y a des particules
qui vont être émises et si cette
personne a une des maladies que le test
peut venir capter et bien il va venir
vibrer et à ce moment-là vous faites
quoi vous mettez un masque vous reculez
et la personne en face il reste à tester
donc c'est des solutions toutes simples
je trouve ça assez malin on le voit ici
au CES la boîte c'est vira warn c'est
très cool d'ailleurs dites-moi vous ce
que vous en pensez est-ce que quelque
chose qui pourrait vous intéresser pour
vous faire tester oui ou alors pas du
tout